قام عملاء خاصون من مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي (FBI) بتنفيذ
أوامر تفتيش على السكان
وصندوق ودائع السناتور مينينديز
ونادين مينينديز في نيوجيرسي.
عندما وصلوا إلى هناك اكتشفوا ما
يقرب من خمسمائة ألف
دولار من النقود
المحشوة في مظاريف وخزائن، وبعض
النقود كانت محشوة في  تحتوي
جيوب سترة السيناتور على
بعض النقود، وبعض المظاريف
النقدية تحتوي على بصمات ديفي
أو الحمض النووي لديفي،
وهذا ليس كل
العملاء اكتشفوا أيضًا الكثير من الذهب
الذي قدمه ديفيز وهانا،
كما عثر مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي بالطبع على سيارة
المرسيدس بنز التي قدمها أوريبي.
العناصر التي كشف عنها مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي تمت
مناقشتها في لائحة الاتهام التي
أشجعكم جميعًا على قراءتها بعناية،
دعنا نلقي نظرة على بعض العناصر فقط
حتى تتمكن من رؤية هنا أن
هذه هي سيارة مرسيدس بنز التي ندعي
أن الخصم الخاص بك قد قدمها  كجزء من المخطط،
ما تراه هنا هو ثلاثة كيلوغرامات من
الذهب،
وتبلغ قيمة هذه الكيلوغرامات الثلاثة معًا
ما يقرب من مائة وخمسين
ألف دولار
وبالطبع هنا يمكنك رؤية
جزء صغير فقط من الأموال النقدية التي تم اكتشافها
كجزء من المخطط